Monsieur le Directeur Général Madame la
Directrice je vous remercie d'avoir
accepté notre invitation pour cette
audition évidemment relative à la
filière automobile puisque voilà c'est
désormais votre activité depuis quelques
années nous avions eu l'occasion
d'entendre la PFA dans d'autres formats
durant la crise covid peut-être vous en
rappelez-vous et plus récemment dans le
cadre de nos travaux relatifs à la
souveraineté économique votre témoignage
est toujours extrêmement éclairant pour
les parlementaires puisqu'il est
transversal en particulier dans des
temps comme ce que nous traversons nous
tenions à vous entendre à nouveau pour
faire le point de la filière du la
situation de la filière automobile
l'édition 2022 du Mondial de
l'automobile a choisi pour titre
révolution is on la révolution est
lancée effectivement c'est probablement
une révolution à multiples facettes qui
touche actuellement le secteur
automobile et cette révolution a
commencé il y a quelques années mais
elle est accentuée par quatre crises que
nous traversons d'abord bien sûr la
pandémie de covid en 2020 qui avait mis
pendant quelques semaines un coup
d'arrêt à la production automobile en
France ensuite en 2022 nous avons connu
les pénuries de matières premières
surtout de semi-conducteur et de métaux
qui vont empêché une reprise à plein
régime si j'ose dire de ce secteur
stelantis c'est d'ailleurs récemment
exprimé sur ce sujet estimant que les
difficultés d'approvisionnement
persisteront au moins jusqu'au début de
l'année 2024 des constructeurs en France
ont encore dû récemment stopper
partiellement le Cher de production je
suis moi-même témoin de chaîne de
production qui s'arrête au moins en
général une journée par semaine de façon
un peu erratique en fonction de
l'arrivée des pièces troisièmement la
crise énergétique bien sûr qui frappe
les industriels aussi durement qu'elle
frappe les Français une récente étude
estimait que la production européenne
automobile pourrait décroître de 40% cet
hiver et jusqu'à la fin 2023 tandis que
les coûts de production de certains
produits seraient multipliés par 10 sous
l'influence des hausses du prix de
l'énergie enfin on peut craindre en
cascade les répercussions de l'inflation
des coûts du carburant et de la crainte
d'une récession sur la demande des
Français en véhicule neufs au cours des
mois voire des années à venir avec ces
crises
50% des chefs d'entreprise du secteur
automobile estime aujourd'hui que leur
situation est mauvaise ou très mauvaise
vous pourrez me dire il y en a 50% qui
considèrent qu'elle est bonne ou très
bonne à l'inverse pourtant dans chaque
crise il y a une opportunité là il y en
a quatre donc il doit y avoir beaucoup
d'opportunités et c'est donc le cas pour
la filière automobile s'engage dans les
transitions d'avenir depuis longtemps
mais je pense qu'il va y avoir une
accélération celle bien sûr de la
mobilité électrique la demande de
véhicule n'a jamais électriques n'a
jamais été aussi forte en proportion en
France Renaud a même annoncé investir
dans son propre réseau de bornes de
recharge électrique avec 200 stations
créées en Europe dont la moitié en
France
ensuite la la
révolution de la réindustrialisation la
France et la filière automobile
française s'engage avec leur partenaire
européen en faveur d'une
réindustrialisation automobile la
création de gigafactory en particulier
dans dans le Nord qui devrait être
facteur de compétitivité et d'emploi et
enfin dans l'économie circulaire avec
l'enjeu du recyclage des batteries
électriques mais aussi du recyclage même
des véhicules j'espère que un jour avant
la fin de cette année parlementaire
j'arriverai à vous emmener sur le projet
refactory de Flins qui est intéressant à
ce domaine donc Monsieur le Directeur
général nous souhaitons vous entendre
aujourd'hui sur la manière dont les
constructeurs français abordent ces
défis comment est-ce qu'on peut aider la
filière automobile à affronter cette
révolution
où en est-elle quelles sont les
perspectives si vous avez une boule de
cristal voilà et probablement plus
d'informations que nous ne vous écoutons
avec beaucoup d'attention
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices très heureux et merci de
l'attention que vous portez à la filière
automobile on en a besoin je vais
essayer de vous expliquer effectivement
un peu la situation la plus
objectivement possible sachant
qu'effectivement je parle le nom un peu
de l'ensemble des acteurs de la filière
automobile c'est à dire à la fois les
constructeurs les équipementsiers et
puis les à peu près 4000 PME et de la
filière dans les différents territoires
voilà dans tous les métiers finalement
qui concourent à la fabrication des des
véhicules je rappelle la filière
automobile aujourd'hui c'est un peu plus
de 350 000 emplois industriels donc sur
l'amont de la filière donc ça a baissé
au fil du temps
il y a ensuite l'aval de la filière tous
les services automobiles c'est de
l'ordre de 450 000 donc au total un peu
plus de emplois directs au niveau de la
filière automobile je rappelle aussi que
l'automobile c'est beaucoup de R&D c'est
une filière extrêmement innovante et
tout particulièrement en ce moment où il
y a énormément finalement de de
transformation à réaliser et
l'innovation est un élément clé je
rappelle la R&D c'est un peu plus de 7
milliards d'euros par an au niveau de
l'industrie automobile c'est de loin la
première filière d'ailleurs en général
dans les classements sur les dépôts de
brevet sur les cinq premières
entreprises il y a toujours trois de
l'automobile il y a notamment des
groupes comme stellantis comme Valeo
Michelin est également très très
pourvoyeur d'innovation et c'est
vraiment au travers de l'innovation que
voilà cette industrie peut réussir aussi
à je dirais tirer son épingle du jeu
dans cette période où tout est en train
d'être refondé alors je commence
peut-être en deux mots madame ma
présidente vous avez évoqué les crises
conjoncturelles puisque voilà
l'automobile est confronté à la fois des
crises conjoncturelles et à une mutation
structurelle sans précédent
sur le conjoncturel effectivement covid
crise des semi-conducteur donc je
rappelle en 2020
2021 alors qu'on espérait que ça remonte
un peu après l'année covid au niveau
mondial plus de 11 millions de véhicules
n'ont pas pu être produit à cause d'un
manque de semi-conducteur cette année on
en est plutôt à 4 millions et demi donc
ça va continuer à monter un peu on sera
pas au même niveau que l'année dernière
mais
conséquence de ça on a vraiment une
crise de l'offre on n'est pas capable de
produire suffisamment de véhicules le
marché automobile a chuté de façon assez
spectaculaire on était pour uniquement
les véhicules particuliers on était à
2,2 millions de véhicules vendus en 2019
on est tombé à
1,65,6 en 2020 on espère remonter en
2021 patatras semi-conducteur même
niveau exactement le même niveau
c'est-à-dire niveau historiquement bas
qu'on a reculé à peu près de 40 ans sur
le niveau de de du marché et 2022 c'est
encore pire on est en retrait
significatif par rapport à 2021 par
l'accumulation à la fois à
semi-conducteur mais aussi disons
maintenant toutes les impacts de la
guerre en Ukraine les augmentations
absolument considérables des cours des
matières premières et maintenant de
l'énergie on peut y revenir c'est vrai
que aujourd'hui je peux vraiment vous
témoigner combien on a de chefs
d'entreprise qui sont un peu tétanisés
sur la façon dont les choses vont se
passer pour l'année prochaine puisque
ils sont confrontés soit signé des
contrats avec les fournisseurs d'énergie
je pense notamment à l'électricité à des
prix où c'est pas viable pour eux ou ils
ne signe pas et on leur dit à ce
moment-là on vous garantit pas du tout
de pouvoir bénéficier donc on pourra y
revenir mais c'est vrai que c'est
extrêmement compliqué on est en très
forte attente des mesures au niveau
européen et au niveau national mais le
temps court c'est-à-dire d'autant que
voilà faut signer les contrats avant la
fin du mois d'octobre pour les volumes
un dit d'arène pour voilà les donc voilà
c'est très très court c'est très très
tendu et effectivement pour le moment
c'est vraiment un sujet extrêmement
prégnant au jour le jour voilà ça
c'était le marché automobile au niveau
de la production la chute est tout aussi
spectaculaire on a connu plutôt des
bonnes années depuis 2014 jusqu'à 2019
ça plutôt remonté l'industrie automobile
en France on est remonté à 2,2 millions
de véhicules produits à la fois véhicule
particulier véhicule utilitaire léger on
a chuté de façon très spectaculaire
parce que on est passé de 2 à 1,350 en
2020 et pareil ça ne remonte pas voilà
alors pour être honnête c'est lié cette
chute à la fois bien sûr au covid et
toute la crise qu'on connaît mais c'est
lié aussi à des décisions qui avaient
été prises avant la crise du covid de
départ d'un certain nombre de véhicules
qui étaient encore fabriqués en France
je pense Clio 208 voilà qui ne sont plus
produits en France donc c'est la
conjonction de ces deux éléments mais la
chute est spectaculaire et je dirais que
ce que je vous décris là c'est valable
sur l'ensemble de l'Europe avec quelques
modulations mais la production
automobile en Allemagne a chuté de façon
extrêmement spectaculaire même si elle
reste beaucoup plus élevée que ce qu'on
a en France mais elle a chuté aussi de
façon très spectaculaire donc voilà ça
c'est juste pour vous donner quelques
quelques éléments de paysage maintenant
sur la mutation
la mutation structurelle qui est tout
aussi spectaculaire je dirais pour la
filière automobile bon moi d'abord je
rappelle que dès 2018 la filière s'est
engagée dans un contraste stratégique de
filière un 2018-2022 à se positionner
comme des acteurs de cette transition
alors transition multiple transition
environnementale avec globalement le
basculement et va y revenir du thermique
plutôt vers l'électrique mais ça suffit
pas c'est aussi tout ce qui est autour
du digital avec des véhicules de plus en
plus connectés de plus en plus
automatisés et globalement on a quand
même une transformation assez incroyable
en termes de valeur ajoutée du hardware
vers le software je dirais assez
simplement voilà on voit bien à quel
point il va y avoir énormément de
services qui vont être associés à la
connectivité des véhicules et des
véhicules entre guillemets de plus en
plus intelligents et puis l'évolution
aussi d'ordre sociétal on va de plus en
plus de la vente de produits à la
fourniture de service avec voilà
beaucoup de transformation que ça va
induire et globalement si cette
transformation on va le voir et
compliquée douloureuse elle je suis
persuadé que
l'automobilité
a beaucoup d'avenir en soi c'est des
secteurs qui vont encore beaucoup se
développer avec beaucoup de nouveaux
acteurs donc l'enjeu ça va être quel va
être la part de valeur que nos acteurs
traditionnels sont capables de capter
dans ces transformations mais faut être
aussi bien conscient que la réussite des
objectifs qu'on se donne sur plan
environnemental ça peut pas être
simplement de passer du thermique à
l'électrique et d'ailleurs on va y
revenir c'est pas forcément
la solution universelle mais c'est aussi
un de réussir à avoir moins de véhicules
à plus haut de valeur ajoutée sur des
durées de vie beaucoup plus longues là
il y a tout un travail voilà pour
essayer et on a des éléments pour cela
et vous citiez voilà l'usine de Flins
est typiquement un des beaux projets qui
visent à pourquoi pas avoir des
véhicules qui peuvent durer 300500000 km
voire davantage c'est vrai qu'il faut
les utiliser plus intensément c'est des
actifs finalement qui sont relativement
peu utilisés c'est toutes les
différentes formes de mobilité partagée
c'est l'intermodalité mais voilà sachant
que l'automobilité la mobilité au
travers de véhicules restera
inévitablement
majeur et central pour la vie de
beaucoup de Français je rappelle voilà
que en milieu rural 95% des gens une
voiture et il y a pas le choix voilà et
ça c'est je pense quand même important
en même temps à rappeler donc on s'est
engagé dans ce contrat de filière
notamment à multiplier par 5 les ventes
de véhicules électriques entre 2018
c'était encore moins de 2% moins de
parts de marché et 2022
moi je peux vous annoncer aujourd'hui
que cet objectif on l'a atteint en fait
l'objectif qu'on s'était fixé c'est
d'avoir un million de véhicules en
circulation en France fin 2022 qui soit
100% électrique ou hybride rechargeable
on vient de passer ce seuil du million
fin septembre donc avec un petit peu
d'avance donc on est au rendez-vous de
cet objectif les parts de marché des
véhicules 100% électrique sont
aujourd'hui de plus de 12%, ça a
progressé progressivement et quand on
rajoute les hybrides rechargeables on
est à 20% un peu plus de 20% de parts de
marché
et je dirais que cet engagement de
monter un peu en puissance vers le
véhicule aucun état d'âme en 2018 de
tout évidence le véhicule électrique est
une bonne solution pour un certain
nombre d'usages il y a aucun doute
là-dessus c'est très bien et d'ailleurs
les gens qui ont basculé vers le
véhicule électrique ont des usages qui
collent bien avec ça elles sont contents
enfin globalement il y a pas de problème
d'acceptabilité du véhicule en lui-même
la conduite est agréable etc après on va
y venir sur voilà l'ensemble des usages
alors depuis 2018 justement donc on a
une incroyable accélération de cette
transition
on a donc au niveau réglementaire le
projet de règlement donc feed for
fifty-five je sais que vous avez
travaillé voilà sur le sujet donc vous
le connaissez bien
pour l'automobile il se traduit par
quelque chose qui nous a quand même un
peu étonné même déjà au niveau de la
proposition qui était le moins 100% des
missions de CO2 en 2035 pour les
véhicules neufs à mis sur le marché en
Europe au niveau de l'émission
c'est-à-dire concrètement
bannissement de tout ce qui est véhicule
thermique ou hybride quel que soit sa
forme et donc on va vers uniquement des
véhicules 100% électrique alors très
clairement nous on s'est exprimé sur le
sujet on s'est exprimé assez fortement
fin juin début juillet
pour dire clairement pour nous il y a
aucun doute de toute façon on est engagé
massivement vers l'électrique il y a on
n'a pas le choix on y va il y a aucun
doute là-dessus en faire la solution
unique aujourd'hui dans un délai
extrêmement rapide là on a énormément
d'interrogations on pense qu'il y a des
prises de risques absolument
considérables parce qu'il y a toute une
série de conditions à réunir pour y
arriver c'est pas tant de produire le
véhicule électrique en tout cas en
dehors de la batterie on y reviendra ça
on sait faire et d'ailleurs les
constructeurs s'adaptent très vite être
capable de faire des chaînes de montage
de véhicules électriques mais il y a
toute une série de conditions à réunir
et on a mis en avant notamment trois
grands enjeux qui nous posent quand même
beaucoup beaucoup de questions sur le
futur dans ce choix d'abord l'enjeu de
souveraineté vous avez là aussi beaucoup
travaillé sur ce sujet pour les métaux
stratégiques c'est vrai qu'on a tendance
à dire faut accélérer le basculement
vers les véhicules électriques pour
sortir de la dépendance il faut cils
mais on rentre dans une dépendance au
point en reparler sur les métaux
stratégiques et on n'est pas prêt en
Europe enfin c'est à dire clairement
quoi donc là on pourra en reparler il y
a eu un rapport de Philippe Varin qui a
été très utile pour effectivement bien
pointer du doigt septembre de choses on
l'a vu avec la guerre en Ukraine des
hausses considérables des cours des
matières premières et le problème c'est
qu'on voit que le surcoût pour un
véhicule électrique est deux fois plus
important que pour un véhicule thermique
parce qu'il y a beaucoup plus de
matériaux stratégiques et du coup ce
qu'on espérait être globalement
progressivement une certaine convergence
des coûts entre véhicules électriques et
véhicules thermiques au contraire on
s'en éloigne parce qu'encore une fois il
y a aujourd'hui un impact plus lourd de
l'augmentation des cours des matières
premières sur l'électrique que sur le
permis et sur des sujets voilà qu'on ne
maîtrise pas par définition qu'on ne
maîtrise pas parce que ça ne se fait pas
concrètement en Europe donc il y a ce
sujet de souveraineté sur lequel on
pourra revenir évidemment les aspects de
lithium de cobalt de de de
nickel mais aussi le cuivre ou tout
simplement enfin voilà il y a toute une
série de métaux qui sont indispensables
pour tous les éléments de transition et
dont les besoins voilà on dit lithium
c'est c'est l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie qui dit on a un besoin qui est
42 fois supérieur à ce qu'on avait
jusqu'à présent donc enfin bien sûr on
va ouvrir des mines sûrement dans le
monde etc mais enfin le rythme ok il
faut répondre voilà pareil assez
vertigineux après il y a les enjeux
sociaux et je dirais à différents titres
c'est à dire il y a effectivement je
dirais le 20e siècle a quand même été
toute une période où le le l'objectif
était progressivement d'être capable
d'offrir
un véhicule la possibilité voilà de se
déplacer au plus grand nombre et c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui quand on voit
l'augmentation considérable des des prix
des véhicules ça interroge par rapport à
ça et donc voilà la période actuelle ne
va pas dans le bon sens là-dessus et
puis au niveau de l'usage c'est vrai que
recharger son véhicule à domicile au
tarif je dirais réguler
ça va c'est même intéressant vraiment
clairement aujourd'hui on se retrouve
dans des situations un peu paradoxales
que d'aller se recharger sur des bandes
de recharge rapide sur autoroute et
haute avec les augmentations absolument
considérables des tarifs qui eux là ne
sont pas protégés puisque là on passe
par des logiques de fournisseurs
d'entreprises là on peut se retrouver
paradoxalement avec des niveaux de coût
de recharge presque plus importants que
le coût du carburant alors évidemment on
espère que tout ça est quand même en
partie conjoncturelle un bien évidemment
mais quand même ça interpelle un peu et
puis évidemment on parle pas de la
fiscalité qui un jour se posera puisque
bon voilà compare deux situations avec
beaucoup de taxes et une situation où il
y en a beaucoup moins
voilà donc ça c'est et puis le troisième
gros enjeu enfin dans les enjeux sociaux
il y a évidemment aussi les impacts dans
les territoires on a mis une étude assez
intéressante pour essayer de voir
l'impact de justement de fit for fifty
five sur les entreprises de la filière
ce qu'on vous laisse et traduire un peu
concrètement pour une entreprise toute
cette trajectoire qu'on a qu'est-ce que
ça donne en pièces et en composant pour
les différents secteurs de la filière et
une des conclusions assez intéressante
de l'étude c'est que on voit que plus
cette transition va vite plus ça va être
douloureux parce que il y a pas le temps
globalement de s'adapter et c'est vrai
que on a on pourra d'ailleurs vous
repasser un des éléments de cette étude
où on a fait beaucoup de scénarios
différents et on voit bien que en ce
moment on est dans les scénarios je
dirais entre guillemets les pires parce
que évidemment il y a un sujet
d'élasticité plus le prix des véhicules
élevés plus finalement le la demande va
se réduire et d'ailleurs on pense que il
y aura sans doute un rebond parce que de
toute façon aujourd'hui il y a un besoin
de véhicule on voit bien les loueurs de
véhicules ont pu de véhicules même
l'occasion récente il y en a plus
beaucoup parce que justement il y a
moins de véhicules neufs etc donc il y
aura un moment un rebond mais
globalement on pense que le volume du
marché ne retrouvera pas durablement les
les niveaux d'avant crise de toute façon
voilà donc au niveau social on est quand
même aujourd'hui dans des pertes de 15 à
30% des effectifs d'ici à 2030 ça peut
faire de 50000 à 100 000 emplois avec
notamment des secteurs qui sont très
lourdement impactés comme la forge la
fonderie le décolletage et en plus ce
sont des secteurs très impactés par la
crise de l'énergie et comme la crise de
l'énergie elle est quand même très
propre à l'Union européenne aujourd'hui
c'est vrai qu'on voit quand même de plus
en plus de témoignages de de d'aller
rechercher un approvisionnement dans des
pays qui ne sont pas impactés par ces
très fortes hausse des coûts donc c'est
une problématique qui se rajoute là qui
mais qui se rajoute à cet élément là
alors ceci dit et je finirai par cet
élément là notre aide esprit aujourd'hui
c'est on est parti il faut réussir on
n'a pas le choix de toute façon et donc
faut il y a plein de risques mais il y a
aussi des opportunités et vraiment nous
notre objectif aujourd'hui c'est d'y
aller d'ailleurs les constructeurs les
équipementsiers les les sous-traitants
ont déjà engagé des investissements
absolument massifs de toute façon il n'y
a pas le choix je veux dire le c'est
irréversible donc de toute façon voilà
on est là dedans alors l'enjeu pour nous
c'est de réussir à attirer les
investissements dans les nouvelles
chaînes de valeur et pour ça on a quand
même des atouts c'est que on a quand
même sous réserve de régler les
problèmes conjoncturels qu'on a à
l'heure actuelle on a l'électricité des
carbonées en France et ce qui est quand
même intéressant dans cette transition
du thermique vers l'électrique c'est que
l'empreinte carbone de la fabrication
d'un véhicule devient de plus en plus
importante c'est-à-dire un véhicule
électrique à une empreinte carbone qui
est à peu près deux fois supérieure
à l'empreinte carbone d'un véhicule
thermique à cause de la batterie qui est
quand même un élément très important et
comme on est bon en France je veux dire
si on localise les activités en France
on réduit un cette empreinte carbone
donc on accentue l'intérêt de localiser
en France les activités qui sont assez
consommatrices d'énergie dès lors encore
une fois qu'on a de l'énergie il faut
évidemment la voir mais si on l'a ça
quand même du sens et donc nous on a
aujourd'hui quand même réussi ces deux
trois dernières années à faire émerger
des très grands projets sur le
territoire national bon je pense aux 3
gigas Factory de batterie qu'on a dans
le nord de la France mais on a aussi
tout ce qui est ce qu'on appelle autour
de l'électronique de puissance avec bon
il y a les moteurs électriques vous avez
un partenariat par exemple entre Renault
et VALEO avec justement des moteurs qui
vont éviter d'utilisation terres qui est
un des sujets qui est compliqué on a
tout ce qui est les chargeurs les
converters etc enfin il y a une série
d'équipements et là il y a des alliances
par exemple avec Nideck qui ont été
développés avec toute une série de
produits l'hydrogène là on peut dire un
mot c'est à dire nous on oppose pas
l'électrique à batterie et l'hydrogène
toute façon on va avoir besoin des deux
l'électrique à batterie c'est très bien
en terme de performance énergétique ça
c'est vraiment très bien donc sauf que
on a ce problème des matériaux
stratégiques et puis l'hydrogène
c'est intéressant parce que ça dépend
moins d'un certain nombre de matériaux
stratégiques par contre l'équation est
compliquée parce que ça nécessite
beaucoup d'énergie à la base puisqu'on
transforme de l'eau en hydrogène avec
beaucoup beaucoup d'énergie et qu'il
faut qu'elle soit décarbonée sinon ça
n'a pas de sens et ensuite il faut
retransformer l'hydrogène en électricité
dans le véhicule qui est la pile à
combustible là aussi les rendements donc
à chaque fois sont pas très bons donc
voilà mais j'oppose pas les deux parce
que de toute façon la solution unique de
l'électrique à batterie et puis pour
certains types d'usage de véhicules
lourds
très intensif il y a un moment où il
devient absurde parce qu'on transporte
d'abord du poids de Patrick donc voilà
on aura besoin des deux mais et
là-dessus on a quand même des
entreprises qui prennent des super
risques mais je trouve intéressant qui
sont du coup à la pointe les michelins
Faures
combustibles Plastic Omnium Faurecia sur
les réservoirs à hydrogène donc c'est de
l'hydrogène à 700 bars c'est ça demande
beaucoup beaucoup de technologie de
développer ce genre de choses mais voilà
on a des projets et puis il y a tout le
sujet de l'économie circulaire qui est
absolument majeur également donc voilà
moi je finirai peut-être un peu par ce
message c'est-à-dire il faut absolument
nous aider à ce que tous ces grands
projets se concrétisent et l'enjeu c'est
un enjeu de compétitivité et c'est vrai
que là la crise d'énergie est quand même
un vrai vrai sujet avec la concurrence
intra-européenne et extra-européenne qui
est quand même très très compliqué vous
savez nous on avait plaidé pour que dans
cette période très très particulière où
des investissements massifs à faire
qu'on puisse à créer des zones qu'on
applique Green Deal c'est-à-dire voilà
des zones qui permettent de recréer des
conditions de compétitivité pour
vraiment attirer les investissements bon
je comprends que c'est très compliqué à
développer parce que faut l'unanimité au
niveau de l'Europe mais enfin je pense
que c'est quand même un grand grand
sujet pour nous et puis je dirais aussi
un peu de stabilité sur le plan
réglementaire sur le plan fiscal bon on
pourra peut-être l'évoquer mais bon là
l'Assemblée nationale dans le cadre du
projet de loi de finances va revenir le
débat sur rajouter le malus masse au
malus sur le CO2 bon avec encore des
changements de paramétrer voilà on
pourra voilà en reparler mais c'est vrai
que notre problème c'est qu'en
permanence les règles du jeu change et
ça c'est quand même très compliqué au
niveau européen au niveau national on a
le projet de normes recette c'est à dire
d'un côté l'Europe dit bah le thermique
plus d'avenir on le condamne et en même
temps ils veulent quand même prendre une
nouvelle réglementation qui va imposer
au constructeur qui voudraient continuer
à faire encore un peu de thermique d'ici
à 2035 de investissement important voilà
le grand risque c'est que tout
simplement les acteurs ils abandonnent
quoi ils ne vont plus réinvestir sur des
technologies qui de toute façon sont
condamnées réglement donc voilà on a un
risque d'accélérer encore quoi voilà le
désengagement voilà donc c'est quelques
mots pour ouvrir un petit peu le débat
en tout cas ravi de cet échange et on
compte aussi sur vous voilà pour nous
aider sur ce chemin mais soyez sûr qu'on
est très déterminé à réussir
merci beaucoup Monsieur le Directeur
général je vais maintenant laisser mes
collègues poser des questions et faire
leurs commentaires j'ai commencé par
Daniel Gremillet ensuite Anne-Catherine
Loisier
oui merci Madame Présidente je suis le
directeur général une fois de plus
et merci pour la qualité de vos propos
moi j'aurais trois questions déjà de
remarques
effectivement tout le monde dit le
thermique c'est fini
mais chaque fois qu'il y a un coup dur
dans notre société qui a une coupure
électrique qu'est-ce qu'on fait
non mais je pose je le dis simplement
et très sincèrement à tout niveau ou que
ce soit donc faisons attention je prends
un autre élément qui est d'actualité qui
est la défense j'étais
on était tous dans nos territoires
respectifs quand on voit notre armée
pour l'instant n'est encore pas
électrique ou à l'hydrogène non mais je
c'est des questions de attention
je voudrais vous entendre un peu plus
sur l'hydrogène parce qu'effectivement
c'est un sujet moi je partage
complètement votre question à votre de
dire attention on était comme ça sur le
pétrole on est comme ça aujourd'hui sur
les batteries vous avez on est dans une
dépendance terrible donc
l'hydrogène même si ça pose un certain
nombre de questionsnements en termes de
coût mais tant qu'on aura c'est comme
les véhicules électriques tant qu'on
n'avait pas lancé les premières flottes
on n'avait pas idée qu'on puisse
l'industrialiser aujourd'hui c'est fait
et aujourd'hui on a des collectivités
des régions qui achètent des flottes
hydrogène donc j'aurais vous entendre un
peu plus sur l'hydrogène si c'est une
vraie ou fausse solution pour le
véhicule léger pour le véhicule lourd on
a déjà un peu la réponse
le Sénat travaillait beaucoup sur la
réforme du code mini et à travers vos
propos là encore je voudrais vous
entendre sur avant nous capacités dans
nos territoires
de produire
ce qui est absolument nécessaire pour
trouver une certaine souveraineté
sur cette mobilité et puis ma dernière
question on va arriver à des croisements
et on le voit aujourd'hui je mets sous
silence le conflit
pétrolier de fournitures mais plus nous
allons avoir de véhicules électriques
moins nous aurons de stations
d'approvisionnement dans nos territoires
et n'oublions pas et vous avez comment
commencer par cela c'est un vrai sujet
parce que déjà aujourd'hui vous avez des
fois des comme-coms qui doivent financer
pour qu'il y ait une station avant de 30
km sinon il y a plus rien du tout et dès
lors que vous aurez moins d'intérêt
économiques donc qui laisser porter tout
cela donc c'est une vraie aussi un vrai
questionnement merci
merci Daniel Anne-Catherine Loisier
ensuite Françoise Ferrat
coucou monsieur pour pour tous ces
éclairages sur un une filière qui est
effectivement frappé de plein fouet à la
fois sur le volet de la matière première
des métaux mais aussi sur le volet de
l'énergie
alors moi j'aurais deux enfin trois
questions une assez globale
[Musique]
vous avez pas parlé en fait de la
pénétration je dirais du marché parlait
tout ce qui est véhicules asiatiques ou
donc comment est-ce que vous l'analysez
quels sont les perspectives
vous n'avez pas non plus parler en fait
du volley de recyclage des métaux est-ce
que est-ce que c'est important qu'est-ce
que ça représente en termes de
pourcentage de de réemploi
et puis enfin je me demandais si sur le
sujet des véhicules électriques on
pouvait pas avoir la même réflexion que
celle que on vient d'avoir sur les
chargeurs des téléphones c'est à dire en
matière de prise est-ce que parce que
parfois on a des gens qui arrivent à une
une borne et c'est pas la bonne prise
est-ce qu'il y a voilà est-ce qu'il y a
une réflexion là dessus pour une prise
unique pour les véhicules électriques
merci
merci Françoise Ferrand suite Daniel
salmon merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur le Directeur et
votre intervention
somme toute confiance que nous avons
ressenti depuis quelques temps en termes
de véhicules électriques ma question
rejoignait celle de mon collègue Daniel
Grémillet sur l'hydrogène vous n'en avez
pas beaucoup parlé je conçois que ce
soit
complexe de mise en oeuvre mais à ce
stade de la discussion je ne résiste pas
à partager ce que j'ai lu dans un dans
un document et qui concerne ce
professeur de mécanique à l'Université
d'Angers qui au cours de
sortir du choc pétrolier de 1979 avec
converti le moteur d'une vieille Simca
essence en hydrogène une énergie qui le
produisait dans son jardin à partir de
panneaux solaires et d'un électrolyseur
alors nous ne sommes plus là mais si je
vous raconte tout c'est que je me suis
rendu compte toute proportion gardée que
nos amis japonais justement étaient en
train de travailler sur cette méthode
c'est à dire que on change de carburant
on ne change pas le moteur donc ça
permettrait de modifier les véhicules
thermiques ce qui en soi sera déjà je
pense une certaine
économie quelque part et ça permettrait
surtout de ne pas abandonner toutes les
optimisations qu'on a pu obtenir au fil
des au fil des décennies sur le moteur à
combustion
ça garantirait je pense à moindre coût
polluant et je voudrais savoir quel est
votre sentiment sur ce sur ce projet
des chiffres là-dessus ça ça m'intéresse
également et puis une question qui a été
un petit peu soulevée tout de suite que
pensez-vous du rétrofit parce qu'on sait
que l'empreinte carbone d'un véhicule et
bien c'est on a je viens de le dire tout
à l'heure c'est sa construction est-ce
que le rétrofit est-ce qu'on est-ce
qu'on avance là-dessus est-ce que pour
vous c'est une une bonne idée qui est
enfin est-ce qu'il y a une pertinence
là-dessus voilà je vous remercie
Cabanel ensuite Laurent Duplomb merci
madame la Présidente de merci Monsieur
le Directeur Général
la première question que j'aurais à vous
poser c'est
pensez-vous que les décisions politiques
qui ont été prises sur l'arrêt de la
production de véhicules thermiques en
2035 justement ces décisions ont été
prises avec toutes les études d'impact
nécessaire notamment et vous l'avez
évoqué dans l'adaptation des entreprises
des constructeurs et les risques
importants d'investissement encourus
la deuxième question c'est sur tous les
constructeurs aujourd'hui
produisent des véhicules et des modèles
électriques ou hybrides mais pensez-vous
qu'ils investissent suffisamment sur les
bords de recharge
comme on le voit sur une marque célèbre
Tesla qui elle a investi énormément sur
les bornes de recharge
pour être usagé d'un véhicule hybride je
tiens à vous préciser quand même la
complexité que l'on a quand on fait de
longs trajets on sort puisque bon à peu
près tous les clients qui ont des
modèles électriques à 80% recharge leur
véhicule chez eux mais les difficultés
encourues quand on est en dehors de son
domicile pour pouvoir charger sur des
bornes ou on s'aperçoit que les
opérateurs sont différents en fonction
des régions chaque région a son
opérateur et donc pour le l'usager il
lui faudrait avoir donc une liste donc
de cartes d'abonnements par opérateur
s'il doit traverser la France est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est raisonnable qu'il
faudrait pas justement harmoniser tout
ça
merci au rang Duplo ensuite Fabien gay
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
pour les informations que vous nous avez
données moi ça m'amène non pas à poser
une question mais à faire une forme de
remarque
est-ce qu'en fait la politique française
ne consiste pas à être sans cesse dans
une forme de sadomasochisme parce que
quand on regarde aujourd'hui quand on
regarde aujourd'hui ce qui nous arrive
et tout ça poussait par un dogme colo
qui n'a pas de faim et qui cesse sans
cesse de nous donner des injonctions
contradictoires mais est-ce que
véritablement aujourd'hui quand on voit
la situation actuelle
on paye l'électricité en pointe 1500
euros entre 1000 et 1500 euros le
mégawatt parce que tout simplement nous
avons pris sous ce dogme
la possibilité en France de fermer
toutes centrale thermique ce qui nous
amène d'ailleurs au mois de juillet
parce que je vous rappelle que les
centrales thermiques et les barrages
hydroélectriques sont les sols les gros
barrages hydroélectriques sont les seuls
qui peuvent faire l'énergie de pointe ce
qui nous a amené l'année cette année au
mois de juillet dans la loi inflation
d'être obligé de réouvrir une centrale
que nous avons fermé
on voit pour le chauffage l'interdiction
du gaz sur les constructions ne ce qui
fait que les communes qui ont fait des
infrastructures sans cesse qui ont
renouvelé les goudrons qui ont refait
les trottoirs se disent aujourd'hui on a
investi pourquoi
on voit le granulé où on a vendu des
poils à granulés partout surtout les
secteurs où on n'avait pas d'autres
possibilités en disant c'est la
meilleure des solutions le granulé est
passé de 200 et quelques rôles à plus de
700 euros la tonne on voit
qu'aujourd'hui on nous parle de
l'électricité pour les voitures on nous
dirait qu'il faudrait faire des bornes
électriques de partout il vous faudra en
tirer du réseau pour les communes
recasser les routes refaire des
infrastructures alors que aujourd'hui
l'investissement pour les communes est à
l'os puisque elles n'ont plus elles ne
dégage quasiment plus d'excédent de
fonctionnement ayant des difficultés à
travers leurs dépenses entre l'énergie
et l'électricité qui sont contraintes et
qui réduisent de façon drastique leur
excédent de fonctionnement alors moi
j'aurais qu'une seule question est-ce
que on a véritablement objectivement
étudier le principe de avoir une analyse
concrète sur la qualité des moteurs
thermiques parce qu'à un moment donné
pour se dire on va tout sur l'électrique
il fallait regarder si véritablement
tous les efforts qu'on a fait pendant
des années ont été vin ou est-ce qu'ils
étaient bons et est-ce qu'on ne pouvait
pas continuer de faire des efforts pour
améliorer le moteur thermique
c'est-à-dire faire que il ne soit de
moins en moins polluants pour pas dire
peut-être à un moment quasiment plus
polluant parce que finalement on se rend
compte que l'électricité si c'est pas
polluant à la sortie du pot
d'échappement ça allait à travers sa
construction sont des mentalement
l'utilisation de l'énergie ainsi de
suite donc la question principale de
tout ça et j'en finis là-dessus est-ce
qu'on est capable un moment d'avoir une
vision plus apaisée plus objective et de
regarder véritablement ce qu'est le
bénéfice risque parce que si c'est pour
aller tout sur l'électrique et demain
éteindre la lumière et dire aux Français
après avoir réduit à 19 degrés vous vous
déplacerez qu'une fois sur quatre je
pense pas que les Français soient
d'accord avec tout ça
merci Laurent je parle on va continuer
d'apaiser Fabien gay et ensuite Evelyne
renaud-garabéeian
merci madame la Présidente c'est le
Président
je regardais le classement des 10
voitures les plus vendues en 2021 vous
le connaissez mieux que moi les Clio la
208 la 2008
la Clio la 208 la 2008 je regardais le
classement des 10 voitures les plus
vendues en France et il faut attendre la
septième la 3008 pour qu'elle soit
produite en France
et moi je suis assez mais c'est un débat
sur le Président j'ai bien écouté
votre propos introductif avec des choses
extrêmement justes sur la question
énergétique je crois qu'ici tout le
monde tout le monde sera d'accord avec
vous mais il y a un problème les
groupements industriels que vous
représentez ne parle plus d'emploi en
France en tout cas dans votre propos
introductif et moi c'est une question
c'est que produire de la voiture quel
type de voiture ça c'est tout un débat
moi je suis d'accord je pense que il
faut de l'électrique mais aussi du
thermique parce que ça va être une
question donc tout le débat est-ce qu'il
faut encore investir dans le thermique
avant son extinction est un débat
mais moi la vocation que devrait avoir
un groupement industriel tel que le
vôtre c'est de continuer à produire en
France ce que nous consommons et quand
je vous entends bon voilà nous dire il y
a un problème sur la question
énergétique qui est réelle enfin on
continue à délocaliser en Slovaquie en
Turquie en Espagne je avec d'autres la
question de la fonderie des Poitou où on
décide c'est une décision politique et
économique de se séparer des fonderies
de les sous-traiter puis ensuite de les
fermer donc moi je pense qu'il y a pas
de fatalité mais il faut en avoir une
volonté politique et économique et dans
votre discours pardonnez-moi et c'est
pas une critique c'est un débat je ne le
retrouve pas donc ça pose question et je
pense que nous devons avoir ce débat
entre l'économie et le politique
pour dire nous avons vocation à
reproduire du véhicule en France et
avoir des ouvriers et de pas perdre des
compétences des savoir-faire et des
usines qui ferment et je suis fini par
là en plus on a un gouvernement qui nous
explique et encore la semaine dernière
alors je sais qu'on va trouver dur mais
qui nous explique que depuis 3 ans tout
va mieux et qu'on recrée de l'empoing
industriel en France et partout on se
déplace on voit que ce n'est pas le cas
malheureusement et la filière automobile
est une grande filière comme
l'aéronautique et on continue à
dégraisser à sous-traiter et à fermer
des entreprises donc je suis assez
inquiet quelle est la vision et le débat
je finis par là que vous avez avec le
groupement industriel pour dire comment
on recrée du véhicule en France on
arrête de perdre du savoir-faire des
ouvriers des ouvriers voilà voilà ma
question je vous remercie merci Fabien
Evelyne Renaud garbédian merci un
Président Monsieur le Directeur général
nous constatons avec vos propres
aujourd'hui qu'avec les le
gouvernementale
est vendu aujourd'hui un véhicule neuf
sur 5 qui est soit électrique soit
hybride rechargeable et j'aimerais faire
le parallèle avec vous par rapport aux
immatriculations des deux roues des
motos ou bien des scooters la Chine elle
bannie aujourd'hui dans l'utilisation
sur les routes dans les villes les deux
roues qui sont à moteur et on constate
que 77% des deux roues qui sont vendus
aujourd'hui immatriculés en Chine sont
électriques alors que nous en France
malgré les aides gouvernementales qui
existent sur les les deux roues les
scooters et le moto on constate
aujourd'hui que simplement 2,28 pour
cent des immatriculations des deux roues
sont électriques est-ce que vous pouvez
me dire pourquoi nous n'avons pas réussi
également à avoir le même succès sur les
deux roues que sur les automobiles merci
merci Evelyne Silviane Noël ensuite
Daphné raqmadou
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur merci pour les éclairages que
vous venez nous apporter élu d'un
département où la sous-traitance
industrielle de rang 2 et 3 en
automobile et particulièrement forte à
travers l'industrie du décolletage et de
la mécatronique je souhaite vous relayer
les nombreuses inquiétudes de cette
industrie composée essentiellement de
PME et de TI puisque dans le contexte de
crise que nous connaissons les tensions
sont particulièrement fortes et je
souhaiterais connaître les actions
engagées par la PFA pour sécuriser le
tissu de la sous-traitance qui est un
maillon essentiel de notre souveraineté
industrielle plus particulièrement
qu'elle responsabilisation des donneurs
d'ordre équipementiers constructeurs
tête de filière pour l'absorption des
hausses d'énergie
techniques et puis quelle fiabilité pour
les prévisions de commandes sur 2023 je
vous remercie
si Sylviane Daphné rakmadou ensuite
Michel bonus madame le Président
Monsieur le Directeur Général ma
question en fait c'est sur le
l'évolution actuellement de la recherche
et des négociations on sait que en la
pointe en fait d'encombrement du réseau
en 20h et aussi à l'heure du déjeuner
est une problématique et
il serait quand même intéressant que les
véhicules et je sais que c'est en cours
puissent être c'est-à-dire que la prise
puisse être à double sens et recharger
le réseau et très injecté dans le réseau
aux heures où ça pose problème
quand on revient à la maison et après
être rechargé plus tard dans la nuit en
heures creuse et je voulais savoir où on
était l'état des recherches sur sur ces
branchements et au-delà d'effectivement
de la prise universelle qui me paraît
quand même assez assez essentiel il y
aura aussi des efforts à faire je sais
que les équipements en maison individuel
sont majoritaires et ne pose pas de
problème par contre dans les copeaux
notamment ça pose problème et voilà et
tant qu'on n'aura pas débloqué ça je
pense qu'on pourra pas décupler on va
dire notamment en zone dense cette
problématique
merci Daphné Michel bonus aussi
franchement
[Musique]
merci juste je voulais vous faire part
d'une expérience et après vous posez une
question une question sur mon
département
j'ai personnellement j'ai mené ma
voiture à réviser et on m'a proposé un
véhicule électrique en début d'été je
vais partir à Béziers autonomie 484 km
je suis parti donc je suis parti serein
parce que j'avais 200 que 190 km à faire
je suis parti serein
j'arrive j'arrive avec ça j'arrive avec
Aix-en-Provence déjà la batterie manger
le 37 % en respectant le code de la
route je commence à dire je vais
peut-être baisser la clim j'ai quand
même 42 degrés c'est un souci je passe
je passe j'arrive pour vous dire à
Montpellier il me restait 23 km obligé
de sortir à Lunel pas de bornes ou les
bornes prises par les taxis je me
retrouve à chercher à chercher un hôtel
donc pour vous terminer un hôtel où le
Gave bien sortir de la pour me donner
une prise en tous les cas je mets 23h
pour la baiser et retour bises répétita
impossible de retourner je me suis
arrêté à Aix-en-Provence encore pareil
hôtel 22 heures pour rentrer à Toulon
lundi matin j'ai vite reporté les clés
j'ai vite posé les clés sur le bureau
j'ai donné moi vite vite au rendez-vous
aujourd'hui on peut rigoler mais non
mais en tous les cas je dans tous les
cas ça va pas fait rire et ma femme et
ma femme s'encline en plus c'était une
bière
Stéphane tactique non
l'impact l'impact 110 km heure 400
chevaux 400 chevaux je roule à 90
bon pour vous pour finir aujourd'hui le
département du Var et le département où
on en fait 40 millions de unités
bien entendu dans les villes et les
villages on a besoin d'avoir une
programmation parce que les bornes
seront impacteront complètement les
futurs investissements est-ce qu'elle
est donnée est-ce qu'on peut est-ce
qu'on peut communiquer pour pour
informer pour informer nos maires et non
président des comme pour les
investissements de rotation qui sont à
faire voilà merci beaucoup
merci Michel qui nous a fait quand même
sourire Franck montoger et pour terminer
Bernard but
oui merci merci madame la Présidente
merci Monsieur pour votre présentation
éclairante
j'aurais une interrogation par rapport
aux propos que vous avez tenus par
rapport à l'impact à l'emprunt vous avez
dit je crois environnemental du véhicule
électrique comparé à celle du véhicule
thermique
est-ce que est-ce que la façon dont vous
raisonner est vraiment la bonne parce
que je j'ai l'impression
en tout cas j'ai compris que que vous ne
raisonniez pas en faisant une analyse
sur le site de vie complet du véhicule
moi je pense que pour faire des
comparaisons qui se tiennent il faut il
faut prendre en compte évidemment la la
construction du véhicule jusqu'à son
démantèlement la récupération de ce qui
peut l'être le traitement des déchets
qui vont éventuellement avec etc et je
pense que en raisonnant comme ça
on change un petit peu les les données
de la de la problématique c'était ma
première question de deuxième question
elle rejoint des des propos tenus par
mes par mes collègues
elle relative à la au réseau de bornes
de recharge finalement
y a-t-il un plan
avez-vous vous-même des démarches auprès
des pouvoirs publics quand au niveau
national qu'au niveau local par rapport
à cette question là voilà comment
a-t-on quelque chose d'avancer sur ce
sujet qui est absolument fondamental
pour la réussite de la de la de la
démarche globale et toujours sur ces
réseaux
quel est le modèle économique
qui vous paraît le plus approprié pour
que non seulement ça se développe mais
que ça que ça tienne dans le temps voilà
en termes de d'investissements
évidemment et également d'exploitation
merci merci
pour finir Bernard merci présidente
monsieur le directeur général des
chercheurs d'un laboratoire de Lyon
travaillent actuellement sur un moteur
thermique convertible à l'hydrogène
l'électrification complète du parc
automobile est en longue à accomplir que
pensez-vous de cette potentiel solution
qui permettrait peut-être la transition
écologique du parc automobile ou au
contraire pensez-vous que l'hydrogène
s'avérera utile unique non pas pour les
voitures mais pour les transports en
commun et particulièrement les
marchandises la plateforme automobile
française regroupe 4000 entreprises
combien souhaitent réellement investir
dans l'hydrogène
merci Bernard à Monsieur le Directeur
Général vous avez fort à faire à
répondre à tout ça sur des sujets bien
divers je vous laisse la parole merci
beaucoup mais j'en suis ravi non parce
que ça balaye bien et désolé il y a des
sujets que j'ai pas pu détailler mais du
coup vous m'en donnez l'occasion donc
c'est parfait alors j'ai peut-être les
reprendre effectivement je vais
commencer sur les sujets hydrogène par
exemple puisque il y a eu pas mal de
questions là-dessus alors il y a
effectivement déjà deux sujets possibles
c'est à dire il y a les véhicules qui
utilisent de l'hydrogène avec une pile à
combustible et c'est un moteur
électrique donc ça on en a parlé un peu
tout à l'heure moi effectivement
est-ce que ça va concerner des véhicules
légers et pas seulement les véhicules
lourds honnêtement j'en sais rien
aujourd'hui dire ce que je pense c'est
qu'on a besoin des deux de toute façon
on voit que pour les véhicules légers ça
sera quand même beaucoup électrique à
batterie pour les véhicules lourds il y
aura certainement pas mal d'hydrogène
après jusqu'où ça peut entre guillemets
descendre honnêtement j'en sais rien je
crois que personne connaissais rien je
pense quand même la grande difficulté
enfin on a parlé des problèmes de
l'énergie qui est quand même un sujet la
deuxième difficulté moi qui ai eu
quelques fonctions dans l'administration
comme directeur général de la prévention
des risques c'est quand même aussi la
distribution de l'hydrogène sous
pression globalement sur l'ensemble des
territoires
qui est quand même un sujet qui est pas
si simple je sais pas si vous avez vu
Porte de Saint-Cloud il y a une station
hydrogène qui a été installée c'est
quand même un sacré truc quoi parce que
ça nécessite beaucoup de protection donc
moi je pense que tout ce qui est flotte
de véhicule ça a du sens parce qu'on n'a
pas besoin de mettre des points de
distribution de façon trop dense c'est
plus compliqué si on veut toucher le
marché des particuliers des véhicules
légers de particulier c'est pour ça que
voilà j'en sais rien encore une fois à
nous toute façon on a intérêt à se
fermer le moins de porte possible vu la
situation dans lequel on est et c'est
pour ça que nous notre message toujours
neutralité technologique plus on peut
laisser ouvert les options
technologiques on va voir comment ça se
passe parce qu'effectivement
effectivement vous l'avez dit je pense
que il y a quand même énormément
d'acteurs qui s'investissent dans
l'hydrogène il y aura certainement des
grands progrès qui ont été fait pour le
moment ça reste très très coûteux mais
en tout cas voilà faut pas se fermer
cette porte là et en tout cas si on
confirme vraiment la fin de tout ce qui
est les carburants liquides classiques
etc il faut bien trouver des solutions
et même si c'est cher ben voilà on
espère que ça va se développer après ce
qui a été évoqué c'est l'hydrogène qui
est injecté directement à la place du
carburant dans un moteur thermique donc
ça ça fait partie aussi de pistes de
réflexion après comme toujours il y a
des avantages notamment de garder des
moteurs thermiques et toute notre
technologie et il y a des inconvénients
je crois qu'il y a des aspects à la fois
bon de rendement et puis il y a des
aspects que si on est dans une approche
hyper rigoriste de la réglementation
zéro émission
à l'échappement bah on n'y est pas tout
à fait c'est des Pouilles m voilà et ça
ça fait partie nous des sujets sur
lesquels on dit mais un tout petit peu
de pragmatisme gardons quand même un peu
cet espace voilà après ce qui est très
expliqué quand même c'est que
l'automobile c'est quand même un marché
de masse et du coup c'est très compliqué
c'est des investissements très lourds
donc c'est vrai que des options qui
concerneraient que des volumes très
limités c'est pas évident et puis après
encore une fois il y a la distribution
qui est quand même un sujet donc voilà
moi ce que je peux dire nous en tout cas
encore une fois on est va il y a plein
de gens qui sont très très prohydrogène
comme la solution
universelle il y en a qui sont très
Antilles pour des raisons voilà
d'énergie nous voilà je pense que ce qui
est important gardons un peu ouvert
toutes ces options et oui je peux vous
dire il y a quand même beaucoup
d'entreprises qui investissent assez
lourdement dans l'hydrogène pour
évidemment la mobilité mais d'ailleurs
au-delà et nous notre difficulté pour la
mobilité c'est que il faut qu'en amont
il y ait toutes les infrastructures de
production de l'hydrogène des carbonée
sinon ça n'a pas de sens enfin
honnêtement si c'est pour faire
fonctionner avec de l'hydrogène gris ça
n'a aucun sens donc voilà or on en est
loin pour le moment on en est quand même
loin parce que voilà ça nécessite
beaucoup beaucoup d'énergie décarbonée
des des voilà donc ça c'était peut-être
un peu sur l'hydrogène sur les bornes de
recharge ça a été beaucoup évoqué c'est
notre sujet numéro un et quand ont été
évoqués ce qu'on discute avec les
pouvoirs publics oui on n'arrête pas de
discuter avec les pouvoirs publics alors
d'abord le côté constructeur c'est vrai
que on a des constructeurs comme Tesla
qui dès le départ ont eu une stratégie
d'intégration complète de tout à la fois
sur la production et effectivement les
bornes de recharge stratégie gagnante
enfin qui en tout cas c'est quand même
un beau succès même si il y a aussi
enfin ce n'est pas un modèle sur tous
les sujets loin de là simplement c'est
un modèle qui va avec des véhicules qui
coûtent 60 000 70 000 bon très bien mais
et on voit bien que les constructeurs
allemands type BMW merci peuvent enfin
cherchent à avoir un peu le même type de
stratégie et il y a notamment le réseau
ionity ou sont associés à un certain
nombre de constructeurs notamment
allemands et coréen et c'est vrai que
c'était lentis comme Renault
pas eu la même stratégie tout simplement
parce que ils ont tellement investir
déjà dans leur cœur de métier que c'est
compliqué d'investir dans tout à la fois
on voit quand même qui cherche à
réinvestir un peu la chaîne de valeur et
notamment sur les batteries on voit bien
qu'il y a une volonté de réinternaliser
pour partie et on voit bien aussi que la
crise des semis conducteurs les amène à
beaucoup réfléchir sur comment retrouver
un petit peu d'indépendance parce que
effectivement il se retrouve quand même
avec des chaînes de d'approvisionnement
extrêmement complexes extrêmement
diversifiée et on a vu avec les semis
conducteurs finalement le peu de de
d'anticipation sur toutes les maillons
de ces chaînes qui sont très complexes
donc il y a cette volonté aujourd'hui ce
qu'on peut dire sur les bandes de
recharge d'abord on nos constructeurs
effectivement commencent à s'impliquer
davantage sur un certain nombre de de de
points il y a des acteurs privés qui
s'investissent de plus en plus parce que
le marché est en train de venir c'est
certain donc on voit que ça bouge bon
dans le contrat de filière il y avait un
engagement que tes pouvoirs publics de
100000 points de recharge accessibles au
public fin 2022 qui avait été même
ramené à la fin 2021 on est à 70 000
72000 donc on en est encore quand même
assez loin et pour nous c'est un gros
sujet et le témoignage que vous avez
apporté malheureusement effectivement on
l'entend énormément donc pour nous c'est
vraiment sujet numéro un donc c'est vrai
tout ce qui est les grands axes bon il y
a tout un plan qui a été mis en place au
niveau des autoroutes mais attention il
y a
un certain nombre d'air d'autoroute et
peut-être bientôt tous vont être équipés
de quelques bornes de recharge mais il
faut aller beaucoup beaucoup plus loin
et puis il faut faire évidemment en
dehors des autoroutes et puis toute une
série de lieux d'où un des grands sujets
à l'heure actuelle c'est que on a
installé aussi des bornes rapides dans
des endroits où il y avait à peu près la
disponibilité en termes de puissance
électrique maintenant il va falloir
anticiper la nécessité de travaux très
lourds sur des postes électriques
nouveaux pour apporter de la puissance
dans un certain nombre d'endroits et ça
c'est 2 à 3 ans de toute façon donc on
est très inquiet quand même de ces
sujets là on continue à pousser très
très fort et c'est vrai qu'on peut pas
demander aux acteurs de l'automobile de
tout faire le dire c'est quand même des
investissements considérables même si
ils doivent être impliqués puisque
évidemment c'est leur intérêt pour
vendre les véhicules voilà mais c'est
compliqué quand même tous les
investissements à faire en même temps
par rapport à ça après a été évoqué le
sujet des copropriétés qui restent pour
nous un énorme sujet je crois qu'il y a
moins d'1% des copropriétés qui est
équipé pour le moment je le vis à titre
personnel ça fait trois ans en plus il y
a les le covid qui fait qu'on n'a pas eu
les assembler général que bon voilà et
c'est compliqué il y a plein d'options
possibles et du coup c'est pas facile
pour une bon et vous avez tout à fait
raison de souligner le sujet des bandes
de recharge
bidirectionnelles parce que je pense que
vu les tensions qu'on a sur le marché de
l'électricité c'est vrai que se dire dès
2030 on aura quand même une quantité
d'électricité stockée dans batterie
assez significative et rien que de
pouvoir mobiliser 5% de cette quantité
dans les quelques périodes de forte
pointe pour les véhicules qui ne
seraient pas à utiliser à ce moment-là
ça a vraiment du sens donc effectivement
nous ce qu'on pense et qu'il faut voir
comment favoriser l'installation de ces
bornes un peu plus intelligentes que les
bornes de base ça coûte un peu plus cher
je ne suis pas sûr que dans l'état
actuel des choses les gens le feront
si il y a pas des aides correspondantes
parce que bon déjà la première priorité
c'est de mettre des bornes quoi donc je
pense que c'est un vrai sujet de
réflexion et je pense notamment à
domicile et en copropriété parce que
c'est là qu'il y a quand même la plupart
des véhicules qui ne roulent pas tous
les jours voilà et qui peuvent
éventuellement être utilisés donc moi je
pense que c'est un grand sujet et je
pense que on a un sujet sur les bornes
de recharge c'est à dire on voit bien
que pour prendre l'exemple de la Chine
ils ont deux fois et demi plus de
véhicules électriques qu'en Europe
ils ont huit à dix fois plus de bandes
de recharge rapide parce que il y a eu
toute une logique de planification donc
il y a des bonnes choses et des moins
bonnes je ne suis pas en train de
prendre la Chine comme un exemple mais
c'est vrai que dans les logiques de
planification on voit bien que on a un
problème de poulet de l'oeuf c'est vrai
que on a des bandes de recharge qui ne
sont pas forcément très rentables encore
aujourd'hui mais il faut absolument
développer à fond avec effectivement des
retours sur investissement qui sont un
peu longs mais c'est indispensable sinon
les témoignages que vous apportez et que
voilà tout le monde apporte ça sera
repoussoir pour aller au-delà des gens
qui ont moins de voitures parce que
souvent quand même ceux qui ont acheté
un véhicule électrique ils ont ils ont
au moins de voitures et ils ont voilà
certains types d'usages bien particulier
donc si on veut aller au-delà il faut
effectivement qu'on règle ces questions
là et c'est vrai que plus on réussira à
avoir un réseau dense de bande de
recharge plus on évitera à mon avis la
course à l'échalote de batterie
extrêmement
forte de cap capacité importante qui
n'est pas une bonne chose en soi pour
l'environnement donc voilà ça je pense
que c'est vraiment un enjeu si vous
pouvez nous aider dans les territoires
c'est vrai que il y a des schémas
directeurs qui se mettent en place il y
a des appels à projets qui se mettent en
place c'est vrai qu'il faudrait
accélérer tout ça me semble-t-il si on
veut réussir la trajectoire qui est
imposée aujourd'hui et constructeur et
les constructeurs l'accélèrent même
cette trajectoire parce que maintenant
qu'on leur dit de toute façon le
thermique et qu'on est plus vite il
bascule vers l'électrique mieux c'est
pour eux donc voilà on craint vraiment
une inadéquation entre l'infrastructure
et puis la réalité de la mise à
disposition des véhicules électriques
après tout ce qui est empreinte carbone
vous avez tout à fait raison que nous on
raisonne en analyse de cycle de vie j'ai
évoqué l'empreinte carbone de l'âme
production du véhicule électrique
simplement pour dire combien ça a du
sens d'essayer de localiser en France
ces activités de production mais on est
tout à fait d'accord que nous et on a
toujours payé là-dedans c'est pour ça
qu'on a beaucoup regretté que la
réglementation ne raisonne pas en
analyse le cycle de vie et je vous cache
pas que des acteurs des pays comme
l'Allemagne ne nous a pas du tout aidé
parce qu'ils sont pas bons sur
évidemment le contenu carbone de
l'électricité donc mais nous pour le
coup s'il y a un pays où ça a du sens de
développer électrique c'est bien la
France et ça on le voit en analyse de
cycle de vie alors les chiffres moi je
vais pas m'asarder à vous donner parce
qu'effectivement on a des chiffres de
partout sur c'est au bout de 30 000 km
de 100000 km 25 ce qui est certain c'est
que c'est intéressant d'avoir un
véhicule électrique ce qui est certain
c'est qu'en France c'est rapidement très
intéressant par le contenu carbone de
l'électricité c'est certain au bout de
30000 37 alors en ce moment malgré tout
le contenu carbone de notre électricité
il augmente hein parce que comme on a de
plus en plus d'électricité importée
voilà mais ça reste il y a aucun doute
que ça reste intéressant dans des pays
comme la Pologne honnêtement on peut se
poser la question et en plus il y a pas
du tout les infrastructures enfin on est
dans quelque chose honnêtement qui est
un peu déconnecté de la réalité et quand
on parle à nos homologues des pays
d'Europe de l'Est pas globalement ils
ont tellement d'autres combats aussi à
suivre que bah voilà l'Europe a laissé
prendre ce type de décision avec
effectivement je ne suis pas sûr que
toutes les études d'impact enfin il y en
a eu des études d'impact mais moi je me
rappelle encore en février que je compte
discutais avec nos collègues du monde de
l'énergie mais il n'y avait aucun
problème pour avoir suffisamment
d'électricité il y a eu plein de
planification qui ont été faites sur le
fait que compte tenu toutes les
économies qu'on allait faire par
ailleurs bah le surplus de besoin de
d'électricité pour les véhicules
électriques ça passerait sans problème
bon voilà on voit bien à quel point on
est dans un paysage qui bouge
extrêmement vite et en tout cas à quel
point on est vulnérable à le moindre
élément et événements et c'est pour ça
que je pense qu'on s'est mis sur une
trajectoire voilà qui est quand même
potentiellement très risqué mais je
préfère éviter tout ambiguïté pour les
constructeurs le débat il est fini il
est derrière nous c'est à dire
clairement encore une fois nous on est
dans une logique faut réussir parce que
de toute façon ça serait catastrophique
qu'est-ce qui risque de se passer si on
est amené à revenir en arrière c'est
comme nos entreprises aurons désarmées
parce que de toute façon ils
n'investiront plus c'est qu'en plus on
risque d'importer des véhicules
thermiques si on n'arrive pas à gérer
cette trajectoire et j'ai pas parlé
effectivement le côté marché enfin
disons les risques d'importation de
véhicule chinois ou coréen c'est une
réalité aujourd'hui la part de marché
des véhicules asiatiques un coréen ou
chinois dans le l'électrique est
beaucoup plus importante que dans le
thermique c'était le verrou
technologique ben voilà qui a sauté donc
voilà retrofit un mot peut-être nous
toutes les solutions sont bonnes
rétrophytes très bien quand ça a du sens
le problème c'est que le rétrofit c'est
pas donné c'est quand même coûteux donc
ça n'a de sens que sur des véhicules qui
ont encore une valeur résiduelle assez
importante on va pas faire des dépenses
de 8000 euros sur un véhicule quand vos
plus que 3000 et qu'il n'aura pas une
grande durée de vie donc nous on pense
que notamment sur des véhicules
utilitaires qu'on a des artisans des
commerçants qui ont en plus développé
une carrosserie spécifique un
aménagement spécifique ça peut avoir
vraiment du sens et notamment on n'a pas
parlé des zones affaiblissement qui vont
quand même être un énorme sujet parce
que aujourd'hui enfin quand on voit les
calendriers qui sont fixés le nombre de
personnes qui vont se retrouver dans
l'impossibilité du jour au lendemain
d'utiliser leur véhicule et on voit bien
que c'est pour ça que toutes les
solutions sont bonnes enfin nous on
n'est pas du tout dans une logique de
dire non non faut pas après il y a des
problèmes de responsabilité faut que ça
soit fait de façon extrêmement sérieuse
mais le rétrophyte pourquoi pas c'est
aussi une bonne solution après sur les
emplois un sachet que
la PFA notre vocation c'est de défendre
l'industrie en France d'ailleurs que ça
soit j'ai pas évoqué Toyota par exemple
c'est une formidable réussite on est
très content d'avoir Toyota et je pense
qu'un des enjeux ça va être de pouvoir
les convaincre que ça a du sens
d'investir en France pour les véhicules
100% électrique pour le moment ils ont
des véhicules hybrides qui fonctionnent
très bien voilà et c'est pareil on a
plein d'entreprises voilà donc nous on
est effectivement là-dessus après
on arrête pas de dire on est sur une
industrie qui est extraordinairement
compétitive on a maintenant des tissus
de fournisseurs extrêmement performants
partout dans le monde y compris
d'ailleurs enfin en proche de l'Europe
aujourd'hui une des grandes
préoccupations le Maroc la Turquie ne
sont pas du tout concernés par cette
crise de l'énergie qui augmente
considérablement les coûts à l'heure
actuelle donc c'est des vrais sujets de
préoccupation qu'on a donc on les
partage on les partage complètement
après la difficulté c'est bien de dire
il faut que les constructeurs ils
fabriquent des petits véhicules en
France mais voilà on est dans des
logiques où il faut qu'on crée les
conditions pour que ils puissent le
faire dans des conditions viables sur un
plan économique et c'est pour ça que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure les zones
grindilles moi je pense qu'on est dans
une situation mais totalement
exceptionnelle que l'industrie
automobile très honnêtement si on la
laisse filer c'est toute l'industrie
parce qu'il y a quand même beaucoup
d'acteurs pour lequel si on retire la
part automobile auront beaucoup de mal
il y a bien sûr des efforts de
diversification qui sont à l'heure
actuelle mais je pense que c'est
absolument fondamental et il faut qu'on
l'a défende mais c'est vrai que ce
basculement aussi rapide vers
l'électrique alors que le thermique
était le cœur du métier avec un
savoir-faire extrêmement fort et c'est
vrai des progrès importants qui ont été
faits on a d'ailleurs des normes qui
sont aujourd'hui extrêmement exigeantes
et les tests qui ont été faits assez
récemment contrairement au sujet du
dieselget aujourd'hui les constructeurs
y tiennent les exigences donc c'est vrai
que rien que renouveler le parc avec des
véhicules thermiques de dernière
génération aurait un effet sur la
qualité de l'air qui est très important
voilà alors après il y a eu le diesel
gate moi j'ai beaucoup travaillé dans
des sujets sanitaires on sait très bien
que quand on a ce genre de sujet pas
après il y a des réactions très fortes
qui conduisent effectivement à des
décisions qui interpellent quand même
mais
en tout cas c'est une réalité
effectivement on a ce sujet mais encore
une fois pour nous il est assez
largement derrière nous en termes disant
de stratégie industrielle parce que
voilà les investissements engagés sont
tellement importants les projets sont
identifiés il faut qu'on réussisse à les
monter parce que ça peut être créateur
d'emploi créateur de nouvelles valeurs
et je finirai peut-être justement sur le
sujet un peu des chaînes de valeur sur
les batteries et le recyclage on fait
des giga Factory de batterie c'est
l'assemblage des cellules et ensuite des
modules et puis ensuite des packs
batteries il y a tout l'amont il y a
tout l'amont
une des grandes parties de la valeur il
y a bien sûr il y a les mines bon est-ce
qu'on sera capable oui on en a en partie
du lithium en France et ce qu'on pourra
ou pas l'exploiter j'en sais rien voilà
oui beaucoup mais voilà après mais après
il y a toutes les étapes au-delà de
l'extraction de Processing de raffinage
et moi je pense que là pour le coup
c'est absolument fondamental qu'on
réussisse à se créer au moins en Europe
et si possible en France une vraie
industrie du raffinage le raffinage de
tous ces plus de 60 65% la Chine
aujourd'hui
on ne fera pas de recyclage
en Europe si on n'a pas l'ensemble des
maillons de la chaîne parce qu'on aura
besoin de ses capacités donc nous on a
notamment il y a un projet potentiel à
Dunkerque sur la plateforme de Dunkerque
après les équations elles sont
compliquées vas-y il faut qu'on accepte
d'abord ce genre d'activité parce que on
veut que du véhicule électrique qui
paraît très propre mais en amont il faut
des activités qui voilà nécessitent et
je pense que pour le coup si on les
faisait en France on y porterait quand
même davantage attention sur le plan
environnemental que dans un certain
nombre d'autres pays dans le monde mais
il faut qu'on le réussisse et je pense
que ça c'est vraiment un des enjeux il
faut qu'on crée toute cette chaîne de
valeur pour le moment les giga factures
de batterie qui sont amenés à monter en
puissance extrêmement vite globalement
elle s'approvisionne là où il y a du
savoir-faire c'est-à-dire en Chine pour
beaucoup y compris d'ailleurs les
équipements pour le process industriel
donc c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on réussisse
c'est-à-dire je pense que l'écosystème
automobile se s'élargit beaucoup les
bandes de recharge pareil aujourd'hui je
crois qu'il y a très peu de fabrication
en France voilà on après voilà essayer
de développer ça et tout ce qui est
économie circulaire va être un enjeu
gigantesque mais encore une fois pour ça
il faut qu'on ait tous les maillons de
la chaîne sinon ça repartira à
l'extérieur de l'Europe parce que de
toute façon on sera pas capable de
revenir à un niveau de qualité suffisant
pour être réintégré dans des patriotes
donc voilà beaucoup de défis magnifiques
et puis dernière chose oui que j'ai pas
vraiment évoqué qui est toujours un
sujet compliqué pour nous qui est sur
l'allègement de dire mais voilà faut des
petites voitures etc
oui alors un oui bien sûr enfin c'est
vrai on peut pas dire le contraire en
soi voilà après un le problème c'est
quand même les véhicules électriques
effectivement non seulement ils sont
lourds par définition avec les batteries
mais en plus soyons honnêtes la forme
type SUV est assez bien adapté pour
avoir l'espace permettant de mettre les
batteries bon
deuxièmement pourquoi on a des véhicules
quand même plus lourds qui a 30 ans
c'est la sécurité passive quand même et
voilà donc c'est vrai que nous notre
difficulté là-dedans c'est que le marché
français est déjà le marché plutôt entre
guillemets de petites voitures par
rapport aux Allemands par rapport aux
Anglais ne parlons pas des Américains et
c'est vrai qu'on a tendance en
permanence à taper sur faut des plus
petites voitures voilà et en même temps
faut les faire en France voilà c'est là
où on dit attention aussi c'est à dire
parce que on a aussi besoin de 3008 on a
aussi besoin de 5008 et d'autres
véhicules un peu équivalents voilà et
c'est vrai que si on est trop en
permanence
à être c'est pas bien c'est pas bien
c'est pas bien tout le temps bah voilà
c'est un peu contradictoire avec la
volonté d'attirer des investissements en
France pour faire les véhicules donc
nous oui l'allègement est un axe
indispensable pour les constructeurs de
toute façon parce que c'est une question
aussi de consommation d'énergie il y a
l'optimisation de l'énergie donc oui
tout à fait l'aéronautique
l'aérodynamique oui tout à fait tout ça
ils y travaillent parce que voilà ça
redevient des éléments majeurs dans la
gestion de l'énergie vous l'avez
expérimenté à vos dépenses et qu'on met
la clim et que il y a toute une série de
fonctionnalités bah voilà donc c'est un
vrai sujet mais ce qui est très
compliqué c'est de dire hop on a qu'à
baissé 300 400 500 kg bah ouais on sait
pas faire on peut remplacer
effectivement certains matériaux par des
matériaux plus légers mais un c'est très
cher et deux ça peut parfois poser
problème pour le recyclage parce qu'on
va faire des composites très très
sophistiqués très coûteux et qu'on a du
mal à recycler donc voilà c'est à chaque
fois des compromis compliqués mais
évidemment c'est quand même un sujet qui
est important et peut-être pour finir
puisque le Mondial est pour bientôt si
vous venez effectivement mondial et on
vous y accueille avec grand plaisir vous
verrez qu'il y a beaucoup de microcar
aussi enfin voilà il y a une diversité
de véhicules il y a beaucoup de microcar
je pense que des mini citadines ça va
être aussi disons pour le moment c'est
pas des énormes volumes mais ça fera
partie effectivement d'une partie de la
solution voilà merci beaucoup en tout
cas Monsieur le Directeur général je
vous garde un peu avec votre avec votre
autorisation parce que on a trois
petites questions supplémentaires et je
m'arrête là après Martine Berthet
ensuite Micheline Jack
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Directeur Général merci également
pour tous les éléments j'aimerais
revenir sur deux points le premier
concerne l'hydrogène et les bornes de
recharge de voiture à hydrogène vous
disiez que c'était très volumineux alors
j'ai un exemple d'une entreprise et
l'entreprise dataway dont vous venons de
fêter les 10 ans et qui effectivement en
a installé alors je sais dans la Manche
mais également deux en Savoie et qui ne
me paraissent pas si volumineuse que ça
en tout cas je pense que nous avons des
entreprises qui innovent et qui vont de
l'avant dans ce sens je l'hydrogène me
semble être un bon moyen de stocker les
énergies renouvelables alors vous dites
qu'il faut beaucoup d'énergie
effectivement pour en produire mais il y
a sans doute des solutions à trouver par
rapport à cela et je pense qu'il faut
vraiment qu'on avance dans cette voie
parce que nous avons besoin là encore
d'un équilibre et de plusieurs solutions
de ne pas aller uniquement vers le tout
électrique et puis alors justement sur
sur le tout électrique les batteries
électriques il y a très peu de
fournisseurs je pense en France il y en
a en tout cas dans la veille la
tarentèse qui est aimé ça MSSA mais tout
spéciaux mais là également il faut
savoir un moment ce que l'on se veut
parce que c'est un
électro un hyper électro-intensif et qui
est en très grosse difficulté
actuellement qui se pose la question de
continuer à produire ou pas par rapport
au coût de l'énergie et si on accompagne
pas nos fournisseurs alors c'est vrai
que ça ne vous concerne pas directement
mais bon c'est une remarque que je
voulais faire par rapport à cette voie
de développement des batteries
électriques si on accompagne pas nos
fournisseurs et bien ce lithium viendra
de Chine plus de voilà de fabrication
nous serons obligés d'importer merci
c'était juste une remarque mais merci
Martine Micheline Jack pour
Monsieur le Directeur dans les
territoires ultramarins ou l'énergie
solaire est prédominante compte tenu de
l'exécuter des territoires le véhicule
pour être une alternative à la
production d'énergie carbonée avec le
développement des smart grid comment
intégrer ces territoires dans votre
stratégie pour en faire des territoires
d'innovation
merci Micheline Henri Cabanel et ensuite
excusez-moi madame j'ai oublié d'une
poser une question tout à l'heure est-ce
qu'il serait envisageable comme pour les
téléphones portables d'avoir la
possibilité d'avoir qu'un chargeur pour
tous les véhicules voilà
j'avais pas entendu excuse-moi voilà et
du coup je crois que Madame Noël attend
sa réponse sur ce que fait la PFA sur
les sous-traitants voilà l'action
voilà ce directeur général voilà
je peux commencer effectivement par le
sujet des sous-traitants
nous c'est notre métier de base enfin
c'est vraiment notre valeur ajoutée elle
est avant tout d'essayer de voir comment
aider accompagner les les sous-traitants
on a besoin des grandes entreprises pour
savoir voilà vers où on va leur
expertiser autre mais notre valeur
ajoutée elle est beaucoup là très
concrètement première objective pour
nous c'est de leur donner autant que
possible de la visibilité c'est à dire
qu'ils sachent un peu moi ce que je
ressens aujourd'hui des chefs
d'entreprise de la filière automobile
c'est que à la fois ils ont compris
parce que ça fait trois ans qu'on passe
au discours que
le débat est derrière nous sur est-ce
qu'on va vers l'électrique ou pas voilà
ils ont bien compris mais de l'autre
côté comme ils entendent tous les jours
que on n'a pas assez d'électricité ils
croient pas voilà donc déjà c'est un
premier sujet qui est passé simple et
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué pour un
certain nombre de PME dont leur marché
intrinsèque va de toute façon se réduire
fortement ceux qui sont effectivement
très directement dans les chaînes de
valeur du moteur électrique du moteur
thermique du diesel d'abord maintenant
de l'essence aussi bah voilà ils peuvent
être très très bons leur marché il faut
absolument qu'ils se diversifie bon donc
nous d'abord sur la visibilité c'est
j'ai parlé un petit peu des études qu'on
faibles bon avec le covid d'ailleurs on
a pu faire beaucoup de webinars etc d'un
certain côté voilà ça permet de d'avoir
des contacts très directs avec beaucoup
disons de PME de Tilly on a je crois
maintenant des relations assez assez
étroites ce qui est compliqué c'est que
ce qui vivent aussi c'est que bon voilà
ils comprennent que ça va baisser mais
en même temps bon il y a tellement
d'effets conjoncturels à l'heure
actuelle et on a vécu là depuis un an et
quelques avec des carnets de commandes
qui étaient passés par les donneurs
d'ordre relativement élevés et puis au
fur et à mesure des annulations ce qu'on
appelle les Stop and Go ou voilà à cause
du manque de composants électronique
brutalement du jour au lendemain on
arrête la production donc du coup en
chêne ça voilà donc ça c'est très
compliqué quand même à gérer pour
beaucoup d'entreprises on a essayé de
travailler avec les donneurs d'ordre
pour essayer de sortir un peu de ces
Stop and Go et d'essayer de planifier un
peu plus ces choses avec plus ou moins
de réussite de la même façon dans les
relations clients fournisseurs qui sont
très dures pour être clair dans
l'automobile mais ils sont très durs
parce que voilà les donneurs d'or de
même se sentent très fortement bousculés
ils ont des investissements à faire
considérables donc bah en ce moment
d'ailleurs ils ont une stratégie de
faire de la marge pour pouvoir
réinvestir donc ils ont un peu le
pricing power comme on dit c'est comme
ça aussi que les véhicules enfin voilà
ils choisissent aussi ceux qui sont à
plus haute valeur ajoutée puisqu'il y a
plutôt pénurie dans l'offre etc donc
mais en même temps quand on voit cette
augmentation très très forte des
véhicules enfin c'est c'est
impressionnant en même temps voilà ils
savent très bien que si ça monte trop il
y a un moment il les vendront but donc
ils mettent une pression très très forte
aussi sur l'ensemble de la sous-traitant
donc là on essaye de travailler on a
beaucoup travaillé notamment pour la
répercussion des hausses des matières
premières là au printemps ça a été très
douloureux ça a été long ça a été
difficile ça a été maintenant à peu près
fait pour une maintenant on a l'énergie
l'énergie c'est encore plus compliqué
parce que la situation de chacun est
différente en fonction de ces dates de
renégociation de contrat etc donc on
peut pas s'appuyer sur des indices
partager pour voilà donc ça c'est
vraiment difficile et moi très
honnêtement ce que je ressens inévitable
c'est qu'en ce moment les constructeurs
de toute façon ils sont en train de
réviser un peu leur panel de
fournisseurs parce que toute façon il y
a une telle transformation vers
l'électrique que il y aura un
resserrement qui est un peu inévitable
donc nous par rapport à ça on a toute
une série d'actions d'accompagnement
individuels d'entreprises donc on leur
propose des dispositifs d'accompagnement
ils choisissent d'ailleurs un peu le
type de consultant qui peuvent et on les
accompagne avec l'aide de l'État au
niveau du financement de ces de ces
accompagnements à la fois stratégiques
et ensuite opérationnel et c'est
notamment la volonté de trouver un
certain nombre de sources de
diversification possible bon on a parlé
du vélo par exemple mais malheureusement
ça remplacera jamais il faut être clair
il y aéronautique il peut y avoir un
certain nombre de choses mais c'est pas
simple de passer de l'automobile à
l'ironique mais il y en a qui
travaillent sur les deux côtés voilà il
y a un certain nombre de voilà de pistes
de diversification mais malheureusement
ça ne permettra probablement pas
d'apporter des solutions à tout le monde
donc après on a le volet plutôt
d'accompagnement éventuellement même à
des consolidations des restructurations
qui a le fond à venir automobile on voit
bien qu'il y a aujourd'hui bah au niveau
du secteur bancaire pas mal de méfiance
par rapport au secteur automobile donc
ça ça peut aggraver aussi la situation
donc ça va être un des sujets en tout
cas nous on a voilà un certain nombre de
dispositif et notamment aussi des
dispositifs pour les salariés pour là on
a beaucoup de grands projets notamment
financés dans le cadre de France 2030
pour voilà accompagner toute une série
de reconversions de personnels par
exemple les batteries on va avoir dans
le Nord besoin d'énormément de personnes
et de compétences nouvelles d'ailleurs
c'est compliqué parce que tout le monde
s'arrache un peu les mêmes personnes
mais nous là on a des grands programmes
pour effectivement former massivement
des gens sur l'économie circulaire à
Flins notamment on a un grand campus un
des métiers des compétences et des gros
dossiers là qui viennent d'être passé
dans le domaine des batteries dans le
domaine de l'hydrogène également dans le
domaine de l'électronique de puissance
etc donc voilà on a pas mal de sujets là
dessus donc ça c'était pour les
sous-traitants peut-être rapidement sur
les stations hydrogène nous encore une
fois on plaide mais à fond pour que on
installe des stations on en a besoin
sinon ça décollera pas voilà après je
pense que ça dépend moi la station dont
je parlais Porte de Saint-Cloud fabrique
l'hydrogène sur place avec un
électrolyseur et ensuite le distribut
voilà donc ça ça va dépendre un petit
peu des situations mais c'est quand même
pas des choses complètement légères et
ça demande aussi un peu de distance par
rapport à tout bâtiment et autres donc
dans des zones
urbanisées fortement urbanisées c'est
pas forcément facile mais on est tout à
fait d'accord enfin nous en tout cas
voilà on dit n'attendons pas d'avoir
d'abord travaillé sur les batteries et
puis ensuite on verra les deux en même
temps on en a absolument besoin voilà
mais le sujet de l'énergie est quand
même un vrai sujet c'est un peu la
schizophrénie qu'on a c'est à dire si on
veut pas d'éoliennes en France ou qu'on
met 12 ans pour les installer les
panneaux photovoltaïques on n'a pas
toutes les régions de France sont pas
forcément très très adaptées pour ça et
après il y a le nucléaire mais bon voilà
le le temps qu'il va falloir pour voilà
c'est c'est quand même un sacré sujet
enfin c'est à dire si l'industrie
automobile est une industrie lourde
l'énergie c'est encore une autre échelle
donc c'est ça un peu qui nous inquiète
quand nous on voit le ban 2035 mais 2035
peu probable qu'il y ait une seule
nouvelle centrale nucléaire en dehors de
l'EPR peut-être qui qui fonctionnera
donc voilà c'est quand même un sujet de
cohérence pour nous qui est quand même
très très réel et un peu de
préoccupation mais donc on est tout à
fait tout à fait d'accord pour ça et
puis pour les territoires
donc type
anti-réunion etc
nous pour le coup enfin on n'a pas très
honnêtement on n'a pas de plan
aujourd'hui très spécifique là-dessus
c'est vrai que le marché de l'électrique
il est naissant donc il faut
effectivement arriver à le développer
bien sûr je pense que ça a du sens de le
développer dans les territoires
d'outre-mer ou notamment l'énergie
solaire peut être particulièrement
développée donc c'est un sujet
effectivement bon après il y a le
problème du coup qui reste un gros sujet
parce qu'il savait être encore plus cher
parce que il y aura jamais la taille
critique pour fabriquer sur place donc
c'est un vrai sujet mais on est tout à
fait d'accord que je pense que ça peut
faire partie de plan un peu spécifiques
comme on l'a fait un peu sur le
recyclage et où il y a des dispositifs
un peu particulier qui ont été mis en
place il faut effectivement qu'on
travaille sur le sujet mais je peux pas
vous dire aujourd'hui c'est encore
vraiment immergent et du coup on n'a pas
de plan spécifique sur le sujet voilà je
sais pas si excusez moi parce que j'ai
peut-être pas répondu à peu près pardon
à oui après les bornes de charges oui
voilà alors c'est clair que on est dans
un processus quand même de
standardisation des prises quand même
simplement pour le moment on a une gamme
très très diversifiée entre les
premières zoées et il y en a encore
beaucoup qui fonctionnent avec des
bornes vraiment de de faible puissance
et puis maintenant de plus en plus
des véhicules qui peuvent être chargés
avec des bornes de 150 kwher du coup on
a une très grande variété pour le moment
de de besoin et du coup on n'est pas
encore complètement dans l'harmonisation
mais honnêtement sur le plan standard
les choses maintenant ont été mises en
place donc ça va effectivement avancer
avant on avait un problème que la
facturation pouvait se faire que sur le
temps maintenant elle peut se faire sur
la puissance enfin sur vraiment la
quantité d'électricité donc voilà tout
ça se met en place c'est en retard à mon
avis par rapport justement au contrat de
filière qu'on s'était donné ben voilà
honnêtement de ce côté là l'industrie
automobile est au rendez-vous
ce côté infrastructure n'est pas
complètement c'est clair et du coup
enfin moi juste peut-être pour finir
pour vous donner un ordre de grandeur
entre aujourd'hui 2030 il faut que le
rythme de mise en service de nouvelles
bandes de recharge soit multipliées par
4 toutes les semaines par rapport à ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui par rapport à ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui donc voilà c'est des
investissements considérables voilà
et bien le mur des challenges est assez
haut Monsieur le Directeur général mais
voilà on a tous j'allais dire on a tous
de l'énergie non mais on en a pas en ce
moment donc voilà en tout cas elle est
très très chère je vous remercie
infiniment pour d'avoir répondu à nos
questions et de ce tour d'horizon fort
éclairant si j'ose ce terme je voudrais
dire à mes collègues que je suis désolé
du délai de prévenance qui est très très
court mais nous avons monté cette
opération merci beaucoup avec vous hier
matin il y a une visite qui est possible
pour les commissaires de notre
commission des affaires économiques
mardi prochain donc vous voudrez mardi
matin mardi matin prochain
je vais vous donner dans la journée je
pense des éléments de de durée de
planning et de programmes voilà
l'objectif je crois que c'est de rester
à peu près une heure et demie sur
le site c'est pas beaucoup parce que il
y a beaucoup de choses à voir mais voilà
c'est mieux que rien du tout donc les
agendas sont compliqués en ce moment
donc je vous remercie beaucoup pour
l'organisation aux dernières minutes de
cette visite et je vous engage donc à
venir voir cette révolution et tous les
challenges que nous avons à atteindre
directement sur le salon la semaine
prochaine en tout cas merci merci
beaucoup pour le temps consacré merci
pour les efforts que fait la PFA pour
l'industrie automobile française qui en
a besoin et ce n'est pas la dernière
fois que nous vous voyons on se donnera
rendez-vous avec régularité merci à tous
pour vos questions nombreuses et je vous
donne rendez-vous à notre prochaine
commission voilà merci beaucoup
ah j'ai deux annonces paroissiales me
disent